[موسيقى]
قالت الشرطه الاوكرانيه ان 18 شخصا قتلوا
بينهم وزير الداخليه الاوكراني ونائبه
وثلاثه اطفال في حادث تحطم مروحيه لما
اصيب 29 شخصا في الحادث وكان رئيس الدائره
العسكريه الاقليميه في كياف افاد بتحطم
المروحيه بالقرب من روضه اطفال ومبنى سكني
في ضاحيه بروفاري شرق العاصمه
الاداره العسكريه عند الحدث تزامنا مع
وجود اطفال من الروضه في الحديقه الملحقه
بها وانه قد تم اجلاءهم جميعا
ومعنى من بروفاريه الشرقيه كيف مراسله
الجزيره كاترين حنا اذن كاترين
نود اخر المعلومات
المتوفره حول سقوط هذه
المروحيه والاجواء المحيطه في مكان الحادث
حيث تتواجدين
بالقرب من المبنى الذي تحطمت عليها
المروحيه او فوقه المروحيه التابعه لقوات
الطوارئ الحكوميه المبنى من الجهه الخلفيه
همم
فيه المروحيه لقد تمكننا منذ قليل من
الاقتراب اكثر من المكان ولكن تم الطلب
الى الصحفيين الى ابتعاد لذلك لا يظهر
ربما الجهه التي فعلا تحطمت فيها المروحيه
والتي تركت دمار كبيره
وكانت قد تسببت باشتعالي حريق عند وقوع
الحادث في اخر المعلومات
منذ قليل وفي حديث خاص للجزيره همم افادنا
رئيس الاداره العسكريه في اكياس الذي حضر
الى المكان لتفقد المكان والاعمال الجاريه
لاجلاء الضحايا افادها بان اخر حصيله حتى
هذه اللحظه هي 18 اا قتيلا وطبعا هناك عدد
كبير ايضا من الجرحى وصل عددهم قبل اا
الان في اخر حصيله الى 29 وافادنا ايضا
بانه يتم العمل على على احصاء عدد الاطفال
الذين ايضا همم هم سقطوا بين قتيل وجريح
في هذا الحادث بحيث ان المروحيه سقطت
منطقه سكنيه تضم ايضا روضه اطفال
المعلومات الاوليه كان قد ذكرت ان هناك
ثلاثه اطفال بين القتل وتسعه اطفال بين
الجرح بالنسبه ايضا لمقاله قريبه للجزيره
همم حسن فان لا معلومات رسميه مؤكده حتى
هذه الساعه حول سبب همم تحطم هذه المروحيه
التي قتل فيها كما بات معروفا وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني ونائبه الاول وكذلك
وزير دوله في الحكومه الاوكرانيه لم تتحدث
السلطات الرسميه عن تفاصيل ما جرى بل تم
طلب رسميا الشهود الذين كانوا موجودين في
المنطقه في اثناء حصول الحادث الى الاتصال
فورا بالشرطه لكي اا يفيدونها بكل ما
يملكونه من معلومات من اجل توضيح ملابسات
هذا حادث ولكن تجدر الاشاره كذلك الى انه
في المقابل ليس هناك اي معلومات رسميه حول
تعرض هذه المروحيه لاي عمل عدائي قد يكون
تسبب في وقوع هذا الحادث ما قاله قليب ان
التحقيقات جاريه لمعرفه الملابسات وايضا
ال- وجه همم وجهه المروحيه قبل تحطمها اذا
هذا هو في
بروفرح المزيد من المعلومات حول الاسباب
الحقيقيه هذه الطائره ولكن في اجواء
الارتباك ربما الذي تسببت به او تسبب به
هذا الحادث في اوكرانيا التي تعاني اساسا
من اوضاع صعبه
نعم فعلا ارتباك كبير ازدهار عند وصولنا
الى هنا
التقينا بعديد عدد كبير من الاهالي كانوا
يسالون عن مصير افراد من عائلاتهم هم
موجودون داخل هذه المنطقه ولا يعرفون شيئا
عن مصيرهم كانت هناك حاله من الهلع
والبكاء في اوساطهم لا سيما وانه يعني عند
الصباح الباكر حصل هذا الحادث كان هذا
المكان همم يعني يعج بالموظفين وكذلك
بالاطفال بحسب ما افادت همم الشرطه في
برافو عليك لذلك همم يعني عدد الضحايا كان
مرتفعا وكذلك يعني هناك ترقب لماذا تنتهي
اليه الحاصيل او سترسوا عليه الحصيله
النهائيه لهؤلاء الضحايا طبعا الوضع هنا
لاسيا وان مشهد الحريق الذي عفوا الذي شب
في هذه المنطقه عند وقوع الحادث كان مروعا
مخيف ااا جدا وما زالت الاخبار تتوالى كما
ذكرنا حول كل الملابسات التي رافقت هذا
الحادث الذي ادى الى مقتل عدد كبير من
الاشخاص بينهم ثلاثه من القياده في وزاره
الداخليه طبعا وزير الداخليه ونائبه وايضا
وزير في الحكومه الاوكرانيه ازدهار شكرا
جزيلا لك كاترين حنا الشرقيه